Views of the police dropped sharply after the
murder of George Floyd. But in several new polls,
they have rebounded somewhat. In a Harris/Harvard
Center for American Political Studies poll,
69 percent said they had a favorable view of the
police, up from 60 percent a year ago. Gallup
reported recently that confidence in the police among whites
was virtually identical to what it was in June 2020,
but that black confidence had ticked up from an
abysmal 19 percent to 27 percent.
Black and white views of the police have
differed for a long time, but in recent years,
white views about unfair treatment of blacks
by the police have moved closer to black ones.
Neither group wants to defund the
police. In a June 2021 USA Today/Ipsos poll,
just 22 percent said they supported
the movement to defund the police.
Sixteen percent of whites and 38
percent of blacks wanted to defund.
Eighty percent of whites and 64 percent of blacks
wanted to deploy more police to the streets.
How confident are you about the police in
your community? Let us know in our poll. Also,
let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.